et banane
mon rêve c'est que ce régime de bananes
puis se retrouver dans la salle d'une
cantine que les enfants puissent la
manger à leur guise
moi je m'appelle gabriel viennois et
j'ai été élevé entre le camembert et la
banane je cuisine depuis tout petit avec
mon père lui c'est un normand un
franchouillard une fine gueule monsieur
festin en quelque sorte
il met de la crème partout dans le
poisson que l'on pêche dans la viande
que l'on chasse et il aime surtout le
beurre avec le pain le pain avec le
beurre avec sa grosse voix on
l'entendait dans tout le quartier
les enfants à table on se précipitait
pour manger on s'est toujours régalé ma
mère elle et polynésiennes avec elle
c'était plus simple manger coco bouillir
le tarot frire le manioc
elle me chantait quand j'étais petit
j'ai faim je veux manger de la banane g
soit je veux boire de l'eau de coco
ok ok cette phrase cette chanson prend
son sens pour moi aujourd'hui c'est
comme ça que je suis devenu cuisinier et
pas chanteur
il y a quelques années lors d'un voyage
à tahiti
j'ai rencontré mon nom a chuchoté à
l'oreille
gab ce n'est pas l'environnement qui
nous appartient c'est nous qui
appartenons à l'environnement cette
phrase je ne l'oublierai jamais c'est
dans ce sens que j'ai ouvert mon
restaurant ici au beau milieu du
pacifique en nouvelle calédonie mon pays
d'adoption commencer par l'environnement
l'environnement culturel l'environnement
congestive c'est dans ce sens que j'ai
monté mon restaurant
il ya une diversité dans les cultures
culinaires en calédonie on peut parler
des kanaks
on y vient et polynésiens les asiatiques
et j'essaye de mettre tout ça en couleur
dans les assiettes de mon restaurant le
menu totalement flexible change en
fonction des produits de saison de ce
que nous trouvons sur le marché en
fonction de ce que nous amène les
pêcheurs et nos producteurs
ce n'est pas le menu s'il n'est pas la
recette qui dictent l'ingrédient c'est
l'ingrédient qui dicte la recette mon
p'tit resto c'est comme un labour
on cherche on teste on applique des
recettes les recettes qui sont bonnes
pour l'environnement qui sont bonnes
pour l'humain et qui procure du plaisir
les recettes bénéfique c'est tout le
concept que je défends le concept est
simple les bons produits
les bonnes personnes et tout le monde
doit être gagnant les personnes qui la
produisent les personnes qui la servent
les personnes qui la cuisine et enfin
les personnes qui la mange
prenons l'exemple de la citrouille
c est un ingrédient bénéfique par
excellence en beignets les pouces les
fleurs sont un vrai régal
grillé avec du pistou c'est ma préférée
l'avez-vous déjà mangé crue râpée
ils sont moins chers que les carottes
importés d'ailleurs et en dessert un
gâteau façon carrée de cake avec une
petite crème passion alors la century
depuis sept ans je sillonne le pays au
gré des formations que je dispense dans
les tables d'hôtes les gîtes les
cantines et en immersion
j'ai redécouvert la beauté des produits
locaux il ya une façon de cuisiner avec
les gens et les produits d'ici et c'est
ça mon projet de vie
valoriser mettre en avant les ressources
locales par le biais du prisme recettes
bénéfique mais il y a un problème
85 % de ce que nous mangeons sur le
territoire est importé mon adn s'agite
et une petite voix me dit fier gab si tu
dois faire quelque chose pour ta
communauté fait le à travers eux c'est
bénéfique j'ai eu envie de changer
d'échelle sortir de mon restaurant
partagez ce concept au plus grand nombre
et si on s'en donne la peine des
résultats sont là je rend régulièrement
visite à mon maraîchers et là d'un choix
j'ai embarqué mon chef de cantine un
chef de cantine avec qui je travaille en
formation et on se promenait dans le
champ et il y avait des grosses gorgées
et je vais demander mais tu fais quoi
avec ses courgettes à nong habite
manière elles sont pas uniformes les
supermarchés nouvelle page et j'ai
vraiment pas j'arrive pas à les vendre
hélas le chef hilde quand il m'a tiré
sur moi ça m'intéresse
ben écoute devant lui ok en fait j'ai
pris machinalement une courgette j'ai
cassé je les goûters rien à dire le goût
était sublime bon c'est un petit peu
tâche et il y avait des choses à revoir
mais à la transformation tout ça cesse
voit plus le chef de cantine on a
commandé sur place 100 kg 100 kg 15
jours après aujourd'hui le chef
le transformateur et le producteur
travaille tant sont au four nir une et
cantines de la fois au milieu de la
calédonie avec lequel je travaille donc
ça a été un peu dur de changer ses
habitudes
mais aujourd'hui c'est chose faite et
c'est rentré dans le cycle mon
producteur lui il ya une plus d'argent
ok maintenant le lien avec le producteur
les chefs
je me suis rendu à lifou une des îles
loyauté de notre beau pays où j'ai
commencé à travailler en fête avec eux
avec les chefs de cantine est en fête
avec deux dollars
il faut qu'il fasse une entrée un plat
un dessert
comment avec des produits locaux peut-on
s'assurer que les enfants puissent bien
manger avec un budget de 2 dollars donc
c'est là dessus qu'on a travaillé avec
cette équipe avec son équipe pour
pouvoir introduire des produits locaux à
la cantine et respecter ce budget
soixante mille élèves ont mangé cet
après midi à la cantine 60 me ces 22 %
de la population
les cantines consomme 5 % de produits
locaux supplémentaires par année
c'est un million de dollars
supplémentaires rien que pour la
production primaire
c'est vous dire
c'est rendu compte malgré la connexion
avec les producteurs avec les chefs tout
le monde était partant que les élèves
par moments bouder les produits locaux
auxquels ils n'étaient plus habitués et
c'est pour ça qu'on a décidé d'intégrer
dans des projets pédagogiques les élèves
c'est à dire en fait ils sont venus
cuisine avec nous on a fait les menus
ensemble on a expliqué un peu ce qui
était les produits on a été rencontré
des producteurs et on a commencé en fait
a co-créé à travailler ensemble sur les
recettes
je peux vous dire que quand ils ont
servi leurs camarades le soir avec ce
qu'ils avaient préparé le midi c'était
le grand sourire et moi quand je pars
après une formation je vois tous les
enfants venir je vais devenir chef je
vais devenir chef
et du coup en fait il ya des projets
pédagogiques qui se sont montés avec la
directrice de l'école et les élèves vont
aussi à la rencontre des producteurs on
met du sens sur ce que l'on mange
alors voilà à travers trois petits
exemples
c'est ça le concept de recettes
bénéfique à grand échelle utilisé des
bons produits
travailler avec les bonnes personnes et
toutes les parties prenantes sont
bénéficiaires et surtout le client final
donc voila moi dans tout ça en fait je
me rends compte que j'active un réseau
je vais mais les gens en relation des
gens qui se rencontrent pas forcément
entre filières entre secteurs mais
simple fait de mettre deux chefs dans
une cantine à travailler ensemble des
deux cantines différents ils se
partagent les recettes les astuces et
c'est comme ça qu'on arrive à intégrer
plus de produits locaux à la cantine
maintenant le travail s'arrête pas là
qu'est ce qui se passe après l'assiette
donc on était du champ à l'assiette avec
toutes les parties prenantes le
producteur le transformateur
le cuisinier l'enfant qu'est ce qui se
passe après de l'assiette à la santé de
l'assiette à l'environnement et je
travaille aujourd'hui avec des
scientifiques avec des nutritionnistes
et diététiciens pour élaborer qu'on
puisse élaborer ensemble véritable
gastronomie de la santé une véritable
gastronomie durable un jour j'ai eu une
conversation avec un docteur tongiens ah
non
et en fait c'était lors d'un buffet un
cabas un breuvage océaniens qui permet
de libérer la parole et ils nous
annoncent tous clairement c'est pas le
réchauffement climatique qui fait couler
les îles du pacifique sud
ce sont les îles qui coule sous le poids
des océaniens devenus obèses alors là on
s'est regardés avec le groupe et quelque
part on s'est dit qu'il y avait urgence
alors que j'imagine que vous aussi vous
voulez tester essayer mettre en place
vos propres recettes bénéfique et je
sais c'est pas toujours facile
on me dit souvent c'est cher les
produits locaux on n'arrive pas à les
trouver
pas en quantité suffisante bref c'est
vrai que je comprends aussi qu'on puisse
être intimidé devant un ananas
c'est quoi ce truc là je vais les
peluches et donc ok on a pensé à vous et
dans un futur proche on va mettre une
plateforme numérique en place pour en
fait vous partager des informations
pertinentes sur la nutrition ou acheter
des produits
comment les travailler des tutoriels des
vidéos des informations simples
digestible pour que vous puissiez vous
aussi avoir des armes pour pouvoir
utiliser ces produits locaux il y à un
ingrédient que vous allez pouvoir
consommer sans modération
la patiente il y en a un autre qu'il
faudra utiliser avec parcimonie le
scepticisme alors dans
smartphone j'ai un nombre incalculable
de contact de tous les maillons de la
chaîne du début jusqu'à la fin
d'ailleurs je crois qu'il est un peu
trop de monde qui m'a plu aujourd'hui
mais en tout cas les producteurs des
petits des gros des je suis dans l'agro
alimentaire aussi des industriels des
transformateurs des nutritionnistes du
transfert technologique et scientifique
ainsi de suite voir des clients qui sont
aussi maintenant intéressé pour
apprendre à travailler ses produits
locaux et la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on
a la banane
depuis la nuit des temps les recettes
nous font vivre
c'est elle qui nous alimente esquisse
qui m'amuse beaucoup en fait au travers
de recettes des recettes simples c'est
que elles ont un véritable impact
un impact sur notre santé sur votre
bonheur sur notre environnement et sur
les générations à venir
merci
pont